first red carpet of the year looking
feeling good yeah it's cold you must be
freezing
Wow yeah you know the good-looking
people heat things up it's okay
I want to ask you director of the year
did you ever imagine that your first
movie would be getting you these kind of
accolades is this crazy never in a
million years yeah I was just hoping
that I would fail miserably it's
vulnerable you know right you know
co-writing and telling a story and
directing it yeah I mean I had no idea
what was gonna happen I just knew that I
had to try so the fact that it's been
well received as you know I just want to
savor it does it make it even more
special that you've got your beautiful
lady here supporting you tonight to know
of course also have to note Bradley
Cooper Grammy nominee did you ever think
that would happen you know that's crazy
is that why could we see her perform at
the Grammys Bradley Cooper well also you
know a lot of movies being made into
musicals now Lady Gaga's said she wants
to do Broadway can we see a star is born
become a Broadway musical one day that's
a good idea I'm hoping for it what do
you think yeah audience is built-in I
mean we have the music yeah and will you
go check her out in Vegas for her I
can't wait yeah I wanted to see the
opening show and I couldn't make it I
was so bummed yeah I'm gonna see it soon
good well good the holidays were good
for you get a little relaxation I've had
a crazy award season huh it's good to
have time at home all right we'll
probably enjoy tonight Sam Elliot
presenting thank you
[Music]